welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and one of my
biggest questions after seeing Black
Adam is how the heck did Amanda Waller
get even more power what exactly is she
doing at that underwater black site
prison who does she have in those liquid
coma Chambers and how did she get the
world's greatest heroes into her good
graces today I'm gonna do my best to
take a sledgehammer to the wall and
speculate on what's happening with
Waller's Shady career let's kick things
off with a quick little rundown of
everything we already know about Amanda
Waller's current standing as the head of
task force x and director of Argus this
woman has an ironclad career dudes I got
fired from Haagen-Dazs when I was 16 for
giving out too many free samples your
fire Waller tried to cover up project
starfish and project butterfly and
somehow she's still employed with full
health care wild the first time we meet
Viola Davis's Waller in the DCU was all
the way back in 2016 Suicide Squad when
she founded task force x in the wake of
Superman's death although her beta test
team went off the rails when enchantress
escaped and turned the citizens of
Midway City into Power Ranger putties
Waller proved that she was Adept at
covering her tracks even if it meant
executing her own team of agents in
order to keep her mistakes buried in
order to keep this particular whoopsie a
secret she struck a deal with Bruce
Wayne a top secret file containing
information on several metahumans
including future Justice League recruits
in exchange for his guardianship against
prying whistleblowers during this
meeting Waller let Bruce know that she
knew his identity as Batman but he
Shrugged off her implied threats by
warning her to disband her task force x
project fast forward to 2021's the
suicide squad and Amanda Waller has
reinstated her task force x project to
cover up the US's involvement with
funding the experimentation of project
starfish while also assassinating and
the American dictator in the process
once again Waller was completely fine
with her own men getting shot and
sometimes she was even the one doing the
shooting when Savant decides to bail on
the beach Massacre she blows his head
off with a nanobomb simply because he
got scared and sheds absolutely zero
tears as the majority of the first wave
of task force x is slaughtered on top of
that she blackmailed Bloodsport by
threatening to imprison his teenage
daughter at Bellerive additionally
insinuating that she'd also recruit her
for the team someday and when starro
rampaged Corto Maltese Walter only cared
about making sure that none of this
could be traced back to the US
government she instructed the squad to
leave all those innocent civilians
including children to die at the hands
of a cyclops starfish from space luckily
Waller was knocked out by her own crew
so that the team could save Corto
malteste from the Kaiju wrecking havoc
on their City Bloodsport and the other
surviving members blackmailed Waller
agreeing to keep quiet about America's
involvement and hers in exchange for
their freedom as punishment for their
betrayal in aiding the members of task
force x the transferred agents Harcourt
and and economos to project butterfly
along with Peacemaker Clemson myrn and
her own daughter Leota adibaya their
goal was to take out an alien race
dubbed the butterflies along with the
cow that they used as a food source
which they succeeded at but in the
aftermath of their Victory adebayo goes
public with information about Argus task
force x the plot to pin everything on
Peacemaker and her mother's very active
hand in all these schemes this was the
last we saw of Waller prior to Black
Adam and my assumption was that Amanda
Waller would finally be removed from her
position as the Director of Argus and
held accountable for her numerous crimes
against humanity at the very least she'd
lose access to her Bellerive Suicide
Squad recruitment program right but
after seeing her role in Black Adam it
appears that Amanda Waller is still
gainfully employed somehow and is
working with agent Harcourt again
despite harcourt's kinship with the 11th
Street kids in the second act of Black
Adam conducts current champion shazams
himself back to normal and agrees to
surrender to the Justice Society of
America the JSA takes him to an Arctic
Supermax Prison Complex hidden deep
Beneath the Sea which has much higher
attack and security than Bellerive at
Bellerive you could still bounce around
a rubber ball in the sunshine here there
is absolutely zero way to reach the
surface without a waterproof stealth
plane or superhuman swimming abilities
so how did Harcourt and Waller land a
job working at an even more super secret
lockdown facility after project starfish
and Butterfly were leaked not only do
they appear to be cordial enough to work
together again it seems like they've
actually been promoted to working with
stronger and theoretically more
dangerous prisoners I've seen some
speculation online from fans who
theorize that Black Adam may take place
before the events of Peacemaker
especially because the movie's release
date was delayed a few times I can see
where these theories were coming from it
is a little weird that Waller is on good
enough standing to run another much
stronger prison but I don't think that
this is the case for one even with black
Adam's delayed theatrical debut this
movie was shot and produced several
months after the filming of Peacemaker
began and two although the dceu's
timeline can get confusing at times
there usually pretty good about
specifying when there's a Time jump or a
flashback basically if this scene was
supposed to take place prior to
Peacemaker or even The Suicide Squad I
think we know it for certain which means
that somehow despite out of BIOS
spilling the T on task force x Amanda
Waller is still entrusted with the
regulation of super beings which to me
means one thing the wall had leverage
it's possible that her exit strategy
involved utilizing the agreement she
made back with Bruce Wayne all the way
back in 2016 but her continued
involvement in the publicized task force
x isn't something Wayne would seem keen
on letting slot it seems like the only
language that Waller speaks is blackmail
so my guess is that she has even darker
secrets about those that could take her
down than they had on her in task force
x this is a woman who always has a
backup plan and an exit strategy also
even though adebayo blew the whistle on
her mother on public news that doesn't
mean anything substantial actually
happened to hold her accountable
adebayo's statement was a plea to have
Waller's role in Project butterfly
investigated but if an investigation did
happen it was just say that they found
Waller at fault there are plenty of real
world examples of internal
investigations going nowhere especially
when you have influential people in your
pocket although if I've learned anything
these past few years about political
spin Waller would likely have to
discredit her own daughter by throwing
her under a bus which isn't exactly out
of character for her if Waller was able
to get control of these allegations
through blackmail and influence then
it's possible that she may have even
pivoted her failures into successes her
team stopped enchantress her team
stopped Storrow and saved Porto Maltese
and her team stopped the widespread body
snatching invasion of butterfly aliens
sure that's not the whole story but
that's all something that Waller could
Sharpie out of the narrative with a few
strategic redactions I'm gonna let you
in on a little secret we haven't dropped
new new rockstars merch in two years two
years but now we've partnered with epic
heroshop.com to finally get some new
gear available in anticipation of this
moment we pulled the audience a while
back so that we could include items you
want like crop tops that's right show
your stuff in this bad boy available in
tie-dye or black you also wanted enamel
pins and we got those these Collectibles
are numbered one through 500 and once
they sell out they are gone think of
them like nfts only you know more real
and less scammy there's also a new
hoodie to show off that you know what
the internet cares about right and now
and if you're feeling casual we've got
two flavors of teas mineral wash and
oversized snagging some merch from epic
hero shop is the absolute best way to
support the channel and wearing that
merch is the best way to spot other fans
in the wild so wear it to screenings
parties or just for everyday new rock
stars host cosplay recreate these iconic
shots and tag epic hero shop to get
featured on their page get everything
you need to be the stylish nerd you know
you are at Epic heroshop.com I also have
a theory about what Harcourt is doing
back in her good graces I actually think
that Waller might be transitioning
Harcourt to Rick flag's former role the
field leader of task force x although
her Victory against the butterflies was
a little messy and she definitely almost
died her Court did rise to the occasion
is the head of the 11th Street kids
after myrn's death Technically she's
gone two for two on successfully killing
space creatures and although she didn't
play by all of Waller's rules she's
earned her respect and if Waller needed
to discredit her daughter writing
hardcore with a massive promotion might
have been one of her better options our
court can be practical so even though
she befriended out of Bio if the wind
was already blowing against her she
might have chosen a safer bet also it
might be worth mentioning that the comic
bases for Harcourt was actually a double
agent working against Waller Russian
agent Amelia Harcourt seemingly has few
similarities with her American dceu
counterpart but it could be possible
that Harcourt is taking a pragmatic
opportunity to align with Waller so that
she can take her down once her evidence
is iron class what I am confused about
however is why Hawkman agreed to work
with Waller to take down teth Adam at
all this whole thing in the movie is
that he believes that real heroes don't
kill but if he hates people who kill
people so much why work with Waller
obviously the JSA wanted to stop Adam
from hurting more people but they took
their direct orders from a woman who
doesn't even blink when her own crew
members bite it that's like if Ted Bundy
told you to tell Jeffrey Dahmer to stop
murdering but she actually still have
Batman and thus the superhero Community
still in her pocket as I said I find
that hard to believe my best guess is
that hawkman's adherence to Justice may
have blinded him to Waller's misdeeds if
Waller did face her daughter's
allegations through trial or
investigative committee and she came out
on top Pac-Man May accept her innocence
this is in conjunction with her position
in keeping metahuman threats who have
been found guilty in lockdown but then
there's the big flag covered elephant in
the room we need to address Superman
according to Waller's implications
Superman showed up to have a little chat
with Black Adam on her behalf because he
owed her a favor but what could that
favor be it's not like she can blackmail
the Man of Steel maybe he felt bad for
showing up late to the butterfly party
and offered to do her a solid the next
time to make up for his tardiness
Honestly though it seems like soups is
just a really nice guy who likes to do
sweet things for his homie he did show
up to Billy Batson's High School Justin
make the shazamoli look cool in front of
a bunch of nose picking teenagers my
guess is that he either owes her for her
role in assembling the Justice League
which led to his Revival or that she
appealed to his mortal weaknesses by
taking care of Martha or Lois in some
way or she's housing a problem that
Superman can't yet solve in that black
site maybe she has doomsdays corpse
locked up which brings me to my next
question who exactly are the other
prisoners stored there as the JSA drops
off Black Adam with his new heavily
armed babysitters Harcourt Muses that
although it's said that the gods created
us we're the ones who always wind up
burying them when she calls these guys
Gods does she mean people with super
powers or does she mean like actual God
Gods because storing a couple of gods in
there would make sense even if the
majority of the prisoners aren't quite
as high powered the JSA and Waller
obviously knew that Black Adam is too
dangerous to store in a prison for
villains like Harley Quinn or Peacemaker
and made a conscious choice to bring him
to the black site inside a water-filled
tank and suspended animation with a tube
down his throat for all eternity Black
Adam wouldn't be able to harm anyone in
his anti-hero form this hardcore
restraint device likely wasn't available
at Bellerive and it's a lot harder for a
villain to escape with thousands of tons
of water pressure barring them from the
surface because of its beefed up
security I think that it's safe to
assume that the other prisoners held in
suspended animation are at a similar
level of risk to Black Adam if not a
smidge weaker I made no disrespect to
the folks on The Suicide Squad but
they're not exactly Invincible we saw
this dude catch a missile with his bare
hands he survived something that should
have given him the Pete Davidson
treatment times 10 billion and let's be
real even powered down Adam could
probably find a way out of there with
his chiseled jawline alone bringing more
god-level beings into the DC EU isn't
unrealistic Shazam 2 Fury of the Gods
promises to introduce us to the
daughters of Atlas and the realm of the
Gods itself it's entirely possible that
other Godlike beings have been defeated
and captured off screen in the DCU and
are now being held at the black site
perhaps even Atlas is in prison which
would explain the daughter's anger with
Billy opening their powers alternatively
it's possible that Amanda Waller could
be building out a more powerful
metahuman task force x out of here her
track record has a lot of debts and she
might be working on an upgrade if you
notice there are some rather large
containers in the background here so if
these prisoners do end up being a future
Suicide Squad we might see members from
task force XL this more muscular
iteration of task force x includes
parasite giganta and Solomon Grundy
parasite and giganta can get real big so
it's possible that they're in these
tubes my other guesses for these big
specimens include camo cinder block and
like I mentioned before possibly even a
regenerating doomsday but who do you
think that Waller has all walled up let
me know in the comments below follow me
on Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
foreign
[Music]